So another big story yesterday, the resignation
of Donald Trump's delusional deprave dystopian.
What other words?
There's many Attorney General William Barr.
He has resigned.
Maybe he got fired.
As with all of these things, we never really
know when a resignation is claimed, whether
it was really a resignation or whether it
was a firing.
But Donald Trump yesterday saying that indeed,
William Barr is departing on December.
Twenty third sort of generally speaking, the
reason given is that Barr wants to go spend
time with his family.
OK, as you may recall, William Barr, was that
last week or the week before.
Time is so weird right now.
In the last couple of weeks, William Barr
came out and said, despite what Donald Trump
wanted Barr to say, Barr said, as of right
now, there is no evidence of election fraud
that would have any impact on the election
results.
And Donald Trump didn't like this.
And many Republicans and Trump didn't like
it, but it was the truth.
And there were rumors that William Barr may
be fired and there were claims that Donald
Trump was thinking about firing William Barr.
This is being called a resignation at this
point in time.
Donald Trump tweeting as if it was all super
friendly and super nice, sort of a nothing
to see here.
Tweeting, quote, just had a very nice meeting
with Attorney General William.
Bar at the White House, our relationship has
been a good one.
He's done an outstanding job as per letter.
Bill will be leaving just before Christmas
to spend the holidays with his family.
Deputy Attorney General Jeff Rosen, an outstanding
person, will become acting attorney general.
Highly respected Richard Donahue will be taking
over the duties of deputy attorney general.
Thank you to all.
Now, hilariously, Barr's letter to Trump is
barely about a resignation.
It's a two page letter.
The entire first page is weaponized brownnosing,
as I'm calling it.
Barr thanks Trump, for letting him investigate
voter fraud.
Barr, thanks.
Congratulates Trump on operation warp speed.
I mean, just a completely sycophantic letter.
It's just a riot.
But then the second page is is like one line.
And on the second page, Baja says, as discussed,
I will spend the next week wrapping up and
will depart on December twenty third just
to sort of casual.
I'm out of here.
So the speculation is that Barr quit or was
fired because he refused to do the things
Trump wanted him to do.
I think it's really important to understand
that while that may well be true, this actually
reminds me of the Brian Kemp situation in
Georgia.
Brian Kemp is the Republican governor of Georgia.
Brad Raffensperger is the Republican secretary
of state of Georgia.
And when Donald Trump was insisting and pressuring
and pressuring Kemp and Raffensperger to somehow
steal the election from Joe Biden in Georgia,
a Brian Kemp and Brad Raffensperger refused.
And there were people saying, look, these
are the these are the good Republicans.
They're unwilling to do this stuff.
Remember that Brian Kemp is disgusting.
Brian Campus secretary of state, ran for governor
and participated in one of the greatest acts
of election suppression, voter suppression
in Georgia when he faced off against Stacey
Abrams.
It's not that Brian Kemp is a good guy.
It's that for just about anybody, there is
a low below which they will not go.
There is there is some place where they say
this I can't do.
And Brian Kemp in all likelihood, recognized
that even if he was able to find some completely
authoritarian way to try to steal Georgia
from Joe Biden and give it to Trump, Trump
still doesn't become president of the United
States.
And so Brian Kemp made the political calculation
that he wasn't going to get involved.
Similarly, William Barr, OK, maybe Barr left
because he wasn't willing to do things Trump
wanted him to do.
Or maybe Trump fired Barr because Barr wasn't
willing to do it.
Look at the things Barr was willing to do,
including that ridiculous four page propaganda
letter making completely incorrect claims
in advance of the Mueller report.
Like Trump was completely exonerated when
the Mueller report said we cannot exonerate
Donald Trump completely from obstruction.
So Barr is no good guy, but it's certainly
plausible that Barr had to draw a line somewhere.
It's also possible that Barr wants to get
out before Trump starts some really humiliating
stuff over the next month, which is expected
to include some absurd short term appointments,
deranged cronyism, pardons that Trump is expected
to give even borderline seditious last ditch
efforts to steal the election.
So Barr is no good guy.
He's horrible.
He's bailing out or was encouraged to resign
or was fired.
And that is as far as we can say it.
Beyond that, Bob Barr is No.
One to be applauded.
Think about how much has happened in the last
three days.
We're so desensitized to the speed of the
news.
The last three days have seen coronavirus
vaccinations start for a hundred year pandemic.
The Supreme Court throwing out a legal challenge
on which Trump and others had hung their entire
expectation for stealing the election.
Joe Biden officially winning the electoral
vote after five months of Trump's lies and
coup attempts and the attorney general, William
Barr, either resigning or getting fired all
in the last three days.
On January 1st, we will have a huge one day
membership special to kick off twenty twenty
one strongly.
And I look forward to having you participate.
Simply get on our mailing list at Join Pakman
Dotcom to be notified
on January 1st.